And what about sets?
They are mutable.
but here
you do not have any keys in indices sets.
Do not have any keys or indices. They have methods to
find an element, but you cannot access.
You know like you would to put our list.
so this is
keyless for like a better words
and because it has no keys.
Which means you cannot?
There is no sort of unique identifier. You
can only have unique values.
So no repetition.
With a tuple I can repeat I can if I want.
For some reason repeat Monday as many times I want.
Okay, I cannot change it afterwards, but I
can have repeat values with a
set. However.
Let's say we have some brands of companies and we do
not want to have any repetition.
Of course sets like in mathematics are
indicated with curly brackets.
but
the elements in a set are not
The other the elements in a set do not
have keys, okay.
In mathematics you can you can like you can magic you put
a subscript to say this is the first element second element, but
not on python.
Which means that because you don't have any Keys associated with the element you
cannot have any repeat values, so if you have some
names of companies, you know like apple again.
Samsung
Nokia and so on
you cannot have repetition.
Okay.